good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so the
health on here joining today's message
is discomfort is your friend over to you
Joe Rogan our bodies for whatever reason
most people their associations are to
avoid anything that's uncomfortable but
it's so illogical because when you look
at comfort and you look at success and
progress and eventual the feelings of
accomplishment and of getting past
certain hurdles and in terms of like how
you feel about life a lot of those are
connected to discomfort like discomfort
is your friend it really is like
discomfort and in not being happy and
content with certain situations in life
or certain feelings in life there are
massive massive motivators and they're
they're amazing at at facilitating
change and yet our instinct is to avoid
those and just sit on the couch and
watch some reality show about do to make
moonshine with our jaw open my groove
it's with bizarre you can measure your
throat is life as a human being
by how much discomfort you're regularly
experiencing there's a little expression
that I use the scary stuff every day
rarely here in songs we hear you know
the radio a hearing on TV you read this
book you have to do something that
scares you every day and it's great
advice
it's amazing advice which is don't do it
like you just open up here open it was a
lot of times this is actually scary
right and when you are doing things that
scare you that's when you see in scene
growth that's when you see yourself
developing your business development and
it didn't happen right away but through
that process of scaring yourself and
getting uncomfortable that's when you
start
amazing things happen and you feel great
you feel scared but you also feel great
because we love to grow because as
humans we want to want to give everyone
more than one develops ourselves and so
what I encourage you to do is try to
develop the habit of you can either
consciousness and presence of the
describe myself every day right we
should be good practice but also keeping
reactive in that way you have an idea or
somebody actually do something and you
get those nerves right you hit those
nervous
that's scary I don't want to do that on
myself you know to recognize that and
then to building growth from that to
start building that muscle of fear and
breaking through it I think it's really
important I think most of what we do is
subconscious I think most of the actions
we take will be subconscious you will
just naturally play call with our
thinking better
you'll rationalize the fear regular
actualize the discomfort you really want
to start a YouTube channel and the real
reason is you're afraid to get in front
of the camera you're afraid of people
judgement of you but instead of
recognizing that just say oh what are
the money's to get a camera at all the
time of your busy life and I've got to
get in here is a lie of the microphone I
don't know I'm in school for this and I
know all of you rationalize the reason
these damages here you're just afraid so
the first type is just understanding
that it's fear that you're really just
afraid of doing this thing and then when
you understand that practice developing
the courage to go and do whenever I see
myself being a little bit afraid worried
about other people's expectations then I
know I have to look into it
so a couple examples I went to Paris not
that long ago I'm speaking on stage at a
keynote speech the close of the
conference wrote 2,000 people in the
room and I've done tons of these
speeches rather than a lot of speeches
and every time I go I want to try to do
something
different not just in the audience
there's the one guys hadn't seen you
before
for myself I would want to get our own
pages to the same speech that I've
always done every time I go on it was
something different for my step until
this time I went up and I didn't do that
if I had one slide the entire
presentation usually had slides that was
tough pictures that falling along the
floor blows things
I don't read some slides I've never done
that well maybe fun when I started with
the slide but this note you know I am 22
the presentation I'm going to get on
stage and uh I'm just going to go and
the initial fear that come ha what is
whatever together I'm going to say what
am i to subtract because the pictures at
least just me on top and what if I
missed a point you know I shouldn't do
it you know the pace to come here and I
need to make sure and provide a lot of
value when doesn't mean just constantly
and all of these peers come in as oh I'm
going to do it I got a does I need to
push myself for me and I was still
nervous there was a guy sneaking before
me and and I should such as couldn't
wait for him to finish because all the
way to his presentation I'm thinking
okay future issue this year they
announced my name instead of walking
around to stage like everybody else does
I just jumped on the stage it's in the
front row every hour a jump on the stage
and the emcee has to come in then shake
your hand up front to the ground beside
I think it's important I think it's
important for yourself that you do the
thing that makes you feel home
compliment I suppose the storage spot my
channel both you can make it because
here I'm worried about people walk in
behind me and do it in the public
setting sort of close the doors are
doing somewhere else or worry different
colored socks because my son did it and
that I was worried that people would
judge me if I tried to do
as I was worried with the judgment I had
to go and do it or listen to music when
I'm walking on the street and dancing
and then when I get close to the
intersection then smaller as soon as you
can see you'll dance smaller sections
you'll play smaller naturally but if you
can catch it that's when you can say no
I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not impacting
these people I'm not trying to make
their life worse right my dancing my
doing whatever I want to do on the
street does it impact them if anything
is giving them something different to
look at bringing a little more joy to my
children to work at the Thomas crazy got
mr. t because they go back to rock with
the Nationals of war if you are I'm
doing and that's inspiring them but
natural thing else you gotta catch it
we going to take the action and so
there's a great expression of doing just
that everyday the spheres we don't
actually do it so encourage you when you
feel a discomfort try to recognize it
try to see it as this is muscle-building
time whoa so the bunch of dates today is
I'm curious what was the last in this
you did that scared you leave doesn't um
fellow really cure dependent I also want
to give a quick shout to freak Willa's
preach thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my post your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed my book so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you LVT
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love and I'll see you get far more
a for another shot of espresso
[Music]
if I had to rewind the clock 10 years I
would have insisted by people that are
close to me that please
push me into very unsafe projects at
least every other one
I think it's professionally responsible
to to not continue to remake the same
group over kids bill what's tonight
Turkey TV dinner Turkey TV dinner so it
looks like you always go out of your
comfort zone right coming on to an
island that was completely deserted no
fresh water you didn't have the money to
buy it and now you're sleeping on a tent
on the beach trying to figure out how to
get fresh water here you do that often
you did it with the airline I mean I was
just somebody that experienced the bad
experience of traveling on Airlines I
was actually trying to get to the BVI
the bridge goes down it's one day from
Puerto Rico and the same lovely lady was
waiting for me and I've been away for
three weeks and American Airlines bumped
the flight and and so I went to the back
of the airport I had a plane hi hard a
blackboard I wrote Virgin Airlines
one-way $29 to the DVI and went around
all the people have been bumped and I
filled my first plane and that got me
thinking you know that Airlines do bump
people they don't care about you or me
particularly in the air and so we and I
then rang up Boeing and said you have
any second and seven for seven okay I
mean it was literally that you just
start any airport and say I'm starting
an airline right now we can I'm
frustrated exactly and I think most most
of the best entrepreneurial ideas come
out of frustration I think you know if
you if you're frustrated about something
and the best way of sorting it out is
get out and do it and you've got
yourself a business starting with
Lincoln Lawyer was down and I said I
wanted to recalibrate my relationship
with my career I remember saying that I
remember thinking my career's I'm
enjoying it I love what it's given me I
like going to work I like the things
I've been doing but everything I sort of
even felt like Oh leave it's another
version of something I've done or I feel
like I could do it next week and I
remember going wait a minute before you
get mad at thinking you could do
something next week that's a valid
feeling don't just say no to something
feel like you can naturally do it then I
said okay fair I'll shave with you on
that McConaughey but let me find
something that I that I don't know how
to do that next week of the week
afternoon kind something that I really
like but I'm going cool I'm not sure
definite scared and it shakes my floor
and I was fortunate enough because that
schedule that check I got him names me
out field to know that I'm I rented
state I was fortunate Phil my kids were
going to eat I was just shepherding the
first son into the world so I had that
to take care of my time and it's a great
kind of going to the shadows and be a be
a father and sit back and see if
something turns you on from the antenna
if something finds you if you go you're
the target that control a over let's
we're okay rents paid kids are going to
eat we can take some time on I know we
was thinking about like oh I'm done but
I didn't know how long the dry spells
going to go so I said no to some of the
things that were similar to what I had
been doing before and it took a while I
had to sit down mage and say hey I'm
really going to do this and I need your
help with my commitment to this because
after eight months succumb the same
thing comes in with the big ten million
dollar pay check it starts to read
better
I just dark Robbie Hugo that means the
same words
is kind of it I think this thing's right
I think I can find an angle I can make
it a different experience from it it
goes so I said I'm gonna need your help
bumper and down there and it's a notice
of things in Selma I need you to be a
gatekeeper one to keep from getting
complete ooh let's do real clear I'm I'm
kind of looking for some different
things to do he hold up he handled that
my wife we said we don't how long he'll
be dry then after they quit finding
those then it did get Dresden nothing
came for about a year there's nothing
and I didn't have any sleepless nights
or oh my gosh I was like no I'm fine all
right
I was writing a lot I was turning myself
on creatively and as I said I had my
first son the Shepherd into the world
and then in the funny thing happened the
beautiful thing happened that somehow
the target drew the arrow and I think my
opinion is I became a new good idea by
being by removing myself I became win
frickin cost Riverside Steven Soderbergh
calls for the first time somehow in that
two years I became fresh new idea that I
don't think I was too three years prior
how that works I'm not sure because I
didn't send a memo out